zombies strippers and Mel Gibson no
matter who they starred these low budget
films surprised people and broke box
office records
an adaptation of the popular John Green
novel The wheat be teen romance The
Fault in Our Stars became a budget
Blockbuster toppling a number of
flashier new releases in June 2014 a
tragic love story starring Shailene
Woodley and Ansel Elgort as terminally
ill teens The Fault in Our Stars opened
against the Tom Cruise LED Sci-Fi Action
flick Edge of Tomorrow and the second
weekend of Disney's Maleficent starring
Angelina Jolie it's still somehow
managed to win its weekend by a
significant margin both of the pricier
projects eventually outgrossed the
underdog romance but given that they
each caused over 10 times more to
produce the Fault in Our Stars turned
out to be the more prosperous investment
and one of the most profitable movies of
the year The Fault in Our Stars raked in
307 million dollars in worldwide box
office and another 43 million dollars in
U.S DVD and Blu-ray sales all on a
budget of about 12 million dollars this
is evidence of how much the movie
business has changed over the past
decade today young adult novel
adaptations without any Wizards or weird
dystopias seem to have straight to
streaming written all over them but
before the outbreak of the streaming
Wars Studios could still count on the
occasional low-budget gamble to pay off
big and cover the cost of a dozen small
future projects in the modern movie
landscape movies like The Fault in Our
Stars simply don't get the opportunity
to surprise us at the box office
welcome to East High High School Musical
is a rare example of a blockbuster TV
movie debuting on cable and then selling
like wildfire on Home Video in 2006 the
musical comedy set a record for the most
viewed Premiere in the history of the
Disney Channel but that was only a
precursor for its massive multimedia
Commercial Success six months later
Disney released the movie on DVD and
reported 1.2 million sales in its first
week on the shelves it's estimated that
High School Musical grossed over 131
million dollars in DVD sales in the
United States alone it was the very
first feature film to go on sale in its
entirety on iTunes as well as the first
TV soundtrack ever to hit number one on
the billboard pop chart according to
playbill High School Musical has since
become a hugely profitable franchise
High School Musical 2 grossed 93 million
dollars on DVD and High School Musical 3
senior Year made the leap to theaters
where it brought home 274 million colors
worldwide the movie itself has been
adapted for the stage leading to High
School Musical the musical the series a
mockumentary series on Disney plus about
high school students putting on the
stage musical based on the movie in 2021
variety estimated that within five years
of its debut the High School Musical
franchise had grossed 4 billion dollars
in retail sales and what was the
production budget for the first High
School Musical Disney's initial
investment in this monster franchise 4.2
million dollars we'll call that a
passing grade there are a few subjects
that the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences tend to eat up like candy
Chief among them being British Royals
and World War II Tom Hooper's The King's
Speech gave them a dose of both telling
the true story of Britain's King George
VI whose stutter was an obstacle to his
duties as the figurehead of a Nation
creeping towards War it's a character
drama mostly centered on the
relationship between George his family
including Helena Bonham Carter as Queen
Elizabeth and the Australian actor who
serves as his speech therapist an
independent production working with a
budget of about 15 million dollars The
King's Speech dominated the British box
office upon its release in 2010 and
gradually picked up steam in the U.S
during the 2011 Awards season by the end
of its long theatrical run it
accumulated a worldwide gross of just
under 424 million dollars and the Oscar
for Best Picture it also lent major
credibility to director Tom Hooper who
would later Helm the disastrous 2019
film adaptation of the stage musical
Cats the lesson here just because a
filmmaker can achieve commercial and
critical success using 15 million
dollars doesn't mean you should give him
95 million dollars to invest in digital
fur technology
love means never having to say you're
sorry interest in Arthur Hiller's 1970
romantic tragedy love story was seated
by a novel adaptation of the screenplay
being written and released while the
film was still in production the book
was a Smash Hit and so was the film that
followed grossing 136 million dollars in
the worldwide box office the equivalent
of one billion dollars after inflation
close your eyes and imagine a college
romance making Avengers money in 2022 it
feels impossible while we can't account
for how much was spent to promote love
story after all the marketing of the
novel should surely be considered part
of the film's advertising budget the
American Film Institute reports that
about 2.26 million dollars was spent to
produce the film less than two percent
of its eventual box office gross no
cinematic Legend has a more humble
beginning than Mad Max an Australian
micro budget film directed by medical
doctor turned filmmaker George Miller
and starring a bunch of unknown and
amateur actors the production and
release of the 1979 post-apocalyptic
Revenge movie was an uphill battle on
every level it was shot over six weeks
on highways that were closed for filming
without permits populated with real-life
Outlaw Bikers using their own equipment
and wardrobe edited on homemade
equipment and banned upon release in
neighboring New Zealand nevertheless Mad
Max performed well commercially in its
native country of Australia and became
an international cult classic
accumulating nearly 100 million dollars
in global box office receipts the profit
margin on Mad Max is almost too large to
believe with the entire production
costing only about two hundred thousand
dollars meaning that the film grossed
nearly 500 times its budget the film's
success launched the careers of both
actor George Miller and star Mel Gibson
and the pair reunited for two
increasingly expensive sequels Mad Max 2
The Road Warrior in 1981 and Mad Max
Beyond Thunderdome in 1985. Miller would
then move on to a wider variety of
projects such as The Witches of Eastwick
babe pig in the city and Happy Feet
when Miller returned to the franchise
with Mad Max Fury Road in 2015. it was a
critical success and a cultural
sensation winning six Academy Awards and
grossing 389 million dollars of course
it was on a budget of 150 million
dollars one and a half times the
cumulative gross of the original film
the franchise continues to expand with
the hotly anticipated prequel furiosa
all on the backs of a small gorilla
production and a budget of under a
quarter of a million dollars
it might
come here yo
Magic Mike is Loosely based on Star
Channing Tatum's real life as a stripper
in Tampa Florida it's assorted steamy
and surprisingly sobering Coming of Age
story brought to life by Master director
Stephen Soderberg balancing the
over-the-top eroticism of the stripper's
nightlives with the quiet and
complicated details of their personal
relationships released in the summer of
June 2012 as perfect counter-programming
against Seth MacFarlane's Ted Magic Mike
never hit the top of the box office but
had staying power throughout the summer
it accumulated a worldwide gross of 167
million dollars on a budget of just
seven million dollars the film's success
led to an even bigger sequel Magic Mike
XXL a stage show a reality spin-off
series and in 2023's series capping
feature Magic Mike's Last Dance
one cut of the Dead is a nesting doll of
great gimmicks in this action horror
comedy a small crew is in the midst of
making a low-budget zombie movie when an
actual zombie apocalypse suddenly Begins
for 37 minutes we follow the bloody
slapstick antics of the actors director
and Company as they attempt to survive
the disaster presented via one
uninterrupted take after that things get
even more wild but not in the way you
might expect one cut of the dead has
grossed 27.5 million dollars worldwide
which doesn't sound like very much until
you consider its shoe string budget of
2.5 million yen about 23 000 US Dollars
it was produced by Film School enbu
seminar as basically a student film
which the student actors actually paid
to perform her variety its success
Beyond its local theatrical run took
Everyone by surprise eventually leading
to it recouping its budget over 1 000
times over the scrappy success of one
cut LED French director Michelle
azanavishus who won an Academy Award for
the artist to create a remake called
Final Cut despite or perhaps because of
its much larger budget of 4 million
dollars the new version failed to
reproduce the charm of the original with
the Oscars gradually becoming less
relevant to the movie going public the
Academy Award for best picture is not
quite the measuring stick for greatness
that it used to be the 21st century has
seen several underwhelming winners like
green book Argo and crash to name a few
it seems almost miraculous when the
academy crowns a worthy Champion so
imagine the gleeful surprise amongst
cinephiles worldwide when bong Joon Ho's
parasite already the winner of 2019's
Palm Door and an overwhelming critical
favorite became the first non-english
language film ever to take home best
picture a best picture win or nomination
reliably lends a boost to a film's
theatrical attendance in the United
States as curious moviegoers attempt to
see as many candidates as possible
before Oscar night and parasite was a no
exception parasite's domestic box office
draw took a sizable jump after the Oscar
nominations were announced and another
after its best picture win that added up
to a healthy 53 million dollars domestic
and 262 million dollars worldwide gross
parasite isn't the highest grossing best
picture of its era but it is one of the
most profitable made with a budget of
about 11 million dollars parasite made
its money back 23 times over not
counting streaming and television rights
next to no one saw a Pitch Perfect smash
Commercial Success coming but frankly we
probably should have this Anna Kendrick
starring comedy about the Misadventures
of a college acapella group was released
in 2012 during the height of Glee fever
and between that television comedy and
the array of rival singing competitions
on broadcast television hi any interest
in joining our acapella group
right this is like a thing now oh toast
the atmosphere was so saturated with
singing that Universal Pictures had
actually put Pitch Perfect on their back
burner for years out of fear that they
might burst the bubble for the ringer it
was only after the phenomenal success of
the Ensemble comedy bridesmaids that the
studio committed to the project with a
modest 17 million dollar budget Pitch
Perfect opened to a limited release in
late September up against Hotel
Transylvania and Looper positive reviews
and Word of Mouth assured that the film
would climb from number six to number
three at the box office when it expanded
the theaters Nationwide the following
weekend actually leapfrogging Looper
investing the weekend's big Disney
animated release Frankenweenie by the
time it completed its theatrical run
Pitch Perfect had grossed 115 million
dollars worldwide its success was
followed by two sequels with
increasingly larger budgets and a
cumulative box office Hall of 588
million dollars the Pitch Perfect
franchise continues to rock on with the
peacock streaming series Pitch Perfect
Bumper in Berlin out now director Danny
Boyle has frequently made a lot out of a
little with his low budget dark comedy
train spotting becoming a cult classic
and his grim and bloody 28 Days Later
winning back its 8 million dollar budget
10 times over his biggest commercial
success however came in 2008 with the
release of Slumdog Millionaire an
independently financed drama about a
young man accused of cheating to win on
a game show in addition to winning the
Academy Award for best picture and
launching the international career of
star Dev Patel Slumdog Millionaire
grossed 378 million dollars worldwide
all off of a budget of only 15 million
dollars at the time of its release it
was the highest grossing independent
film in the history of the British movie
industry though it was eventually
dethroned by The King's Speech you might
imagine that the film being set in India
home to one of the world's biggest film
Industries and a film loving culture
would be a major contributor to its
Global box office success however you'd
be imagining incorrectly while a big hit
in many other International markets
Slumdog Millionaire was not as well
received in India where critics and
audiences were displeased with the
film's portrayal of their country as
impoverished and corrupt some Indians
were justifiably displeased when a movie
copying some of their style but made by
an English filmmaker was hailed as a
worldwide sensation while British and
American audiences continue to overlook
the Indian movies from which it drew
influence
thank you
foreign